Well, basically it is the preparation or the
beginnings for the preparation of the
European Union-CELAC summit that will be taking
place on October 26 and 27 in
San Salvador and we want to invite all
the delegations of the European Union
to join us in this summit
that  It is very important in the new
moment that the world is experiencing in the
sense of strengthening the alliances between
the European Union and the community of
Latin American and Caribbean states.
We seek to strengthen this
alliance between the European Union and
Latin America around three common or
shared themes  first, our positions
regarding climate change, the
commitments we have acquired and the
implementation of those commitments,
second, our position regarding
multilateralism, that we want an increasingly inclusive multilateralism that is
stronger and allows us to address the
different challenges it faces,
and third, we also seek to establish
positions  common to a system  An
increasingly
open, increasingly inclusive international economic framework that
allows us a fluid
and fair commercial exchange between the different sectors of
the planet, but particularly between the
European Union and the member countries of
the community of Latin American
and Caribbean states, we have common values.
Historical events, we also have
common positions on current issues and it is
the right time to strengthen this
alliance between Latin America and the Caribbean
together with Europe, building bridges
between both sides of the Atlantic